Coming this year.
This is about everything to the Hulu
Disney Plus bundle.
Hang on.
Epic adventures on Disney Plus,
this is just the beginning
and stories you'll love on Hulu, Hulu
and Disney Plus together.
Spot on. All of these and more streaming soon.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie.
This will be my new Loki Season
2 trailer video.
They released the new footage
and clarified
what's going on with that Victor
Timely Kang
Post-Credits scene and how it fits
into the events of Loki Season two.
It's meant to be a scene
directly out of Loki Season two.
We also finally got a release date
for Loki Season two,
so we have an idea
what episodes are going to come.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes.
Of course I'll do videos
for all the episodes
just like I did for season one.
Before that happens,
we'll get the Secret Invasion episodes.
There's a little bit of footage
for that during this trailer too.
Those episodes are supposed to come
sometime in late April, maybe early May.
But the producers for Amon
and the WASP, Quantumania
and the Producers for Loki Season
two revealed that the Post-Credits scene
with Loki and Mobius watching Victor
Timely Kang is actually a scene taken
directly out of Loki season
two episodes like it wasn't
meant to be a completely separate
one off thing.
The Loki Season two crew filmed that scene
while they were in the middle of filming
the rest of the Loki season two episodes.
Because a lot of the Loki season
two episodes will be Mobius
and Loki going around time and space
looking for different variants of Kang,
and this just happens to be one of them.
But in the second Post-Credits scene,
it starts in the late 1800s.
It's meant to be around the same time
period as Thomas Edison
and Nicholas Tesla
arguing about DC versus AC current,
but it's the Victor timely variant of Kang
Giving a presentation
for a small theater audience
about controlling time the same way
that Thomas Edison or Nikola Tesla
would talk about controlling electricity.
His banner reads Victor
Timely and his astounding temporal marvel.
As in Marvel Comics,
the name Victor Timely is also a reference
to the real world
origin of Marvel Comics.
A long time ago, a young Stan
Lee was hired by Martin Goodman,
who owned Timely Comics,
which then became Atlas Comics
and then became Marvel Comics.
There's been a lot of references
to the real world origin of Marvel Comics
in a lot of the other Loki season.
Two scenes in different episodes
as well, too.
The Victor Timely was a version of Kang
that decided the smartest way to get rid
of The Avengers was to start in the past,
and he traveled back to 1901 in Wisconsin
instead at this business that he wanted
to use to take over the planet.
What they're doing with the character
during Loki Season two
is a bit divergent
from what they did in the comics.
They change a bunch of stuff
because in the comics
eventually it was his son Victor,
Timely Junior, then Victor time,
the third in present day
that wound up fighting The Avengers
during the Post-Credits scene
in Loki Season two.
This is just meant to be a variant of came
from a different universe
and it's just this victor timely version
that they're going up against.
They're not going to be facing the next
ten generations of this variant of Kang,
all the other different things
that they face during the season.
And Kang will be in many different
episodes, as many different variants
will all be from different universes.
And it seems like he's showing off
a primitive time
travel device using old timey technology,
and he's basically pitching the audience
about controlling time,
which is what all the Kang
variants are doing.
Are trying to do, he says.
Time is everything.
It shapes our lives,
but perhaps we can shape it.
Then they reveal in the crowd.
Loki and Mobius are they're on a
TB assignment with Loki just deadly
afraid of him in trying to convince Mobius
what a threat Kang Variants are like.
That's in. That's the guy
I've been telling you about.
A mobius not really understanding
why he's so dangerous
because he's from the rebooted timeline
and has no memories
from the events of Loki Season one.
And I think the idea here
is that a version of Kang just went back
into the past in the late 18th
hundreds in his trying to change history
from this point in the past
in part of Loki, Season two will be
then trying to stop Kang variants in him,
trying to convince them about the dangers
of the Kang Multiverse war
and what's really going on
with the Council of Kang's.
The next much bigger scene is in the back
alley of a special theater
where they've come to stop a new Nexus
event involving the zany character
from Marvel Comics.
I've already done
a longer video about this
because we saw a bunch of
footage from this
and there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
for all the fake movies
inside the Marvel Universe.
But the reason why they're dressed
in tuxedos that look like that
all old timey is
because this is taking place in the 1970s.
London Like they actually go back in time
to stop the Nexus event.
And it's at this movie
premiere at this London theater.
And in the scene, you probably recognize
Loki is using the same magic trick
that he used in the first Avengers movie
to duplicate himself with illusions.
And Mobius is just making fun of him.
Like, isn't this a bit much?
I could be in a bit showy,
even though that's totally Loki's style
to be super showy and over-the-top.
Because the movie that's premiering
here is the Zany Act movie,
which itself is a comic book character.
So it's like a reference
within a reference within a reference
in, if you zoom in, enhanced on the movie
poster credits here
for all the other actors
names, the production crew members
names, the production company is listed
as a Goodman production.
That's a huge strike for the origin
of the Marvel comic book company itself.
So it's a very meta episode
because Maniac himself is sort of
like a parody on comic book
characters inside the MCU.
And at this particular movie theater,
there's a bunch of those fake in universe
MCU movies that themselves are references
to other real life Marvel movies
like King Goes Original movie
is also playing at this movie theater
because this is in the 1970s.
This scene of Loki, with the severed head
of the timekeeper robot is with Mobius,
the other two agents nearby,
and they're just out of frame.
This is one of the scenes
they released in the D23 trailer
but didn't allow online in the scene.
It's still early in the series
when Loki's trying to explain
everything that happened in season
one to Mobius, the other TVA agents
who are part of the new timeline created
after he remains King was killed by Sylvie
in the timeline rebooted.
None of them have memories
of what happened
during season one
except for Ravonna Renslayer.
She's not here in any of this footage.
She escaped during season one,
but she will be back during season two.
In the scene is meant to play out
like a faster version
of the Big Timekeepers,
Kang revealed during season one,
where Loki uses
one of the quantum energy batons
they use to prune things to destroy this
wall, a mural depicting the timekeepers
holding the sacred timeline.
He destroys the outer mural here to reveal
another giant golden statue behind it.
Kind of like the statues
of the timekeepers.
Above are one translator in her judges
desk.
Only a giant golden one revealed by him
destroying this wall.
And it's supposed to be the Kang
the Conqueror that's meant
to be ruling over this version of the TVA
in the new rebooted timeline.
You notice he looks a little bit different
from the variant of Kang
the Conqueror that we see in Ant-Man
and the WASP.
Like he doesn't have the scars.
His haircut is very different,
so I think it's meant
to be a different Kang variant,
but part of the idea
during Loki Season two
is that when Sylvie sends him back
to the timeline that has rebooted the TVA,
this Kang is currently winning
the K Multiverse war, created the TVA,
but he's mysterious,
only missing from the TVA in the same way
that during season one
you didn't really see he who remains
until the end of the season, even though
his presence was felt everywhere
in per that first Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania Post-Credits
scene with the Council of Kang's
meeting in the leadership.
They're like the Rama Kang
with the Scarlet Centurion version of Kang
now confirmed to be the Scarlet Centurion
by the director of Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania
just a slightly different looking version
of the Scarlet Centurion in the True
Immortals version, presiding over their
meeting, getting ready to declare war
on everybody
from the different universes, The Avengers
from different universes that are starting
to, quote unquote, touch the multiverse.
So a version of the next Kang Multiverse
War is playing out
again, while Loki Season two
is happening in the background
in the variant of Kang that was running
the TVA here is busy with that.
Like he's
fighting the Kang Multiverse war,
so he's not around for minor day to day
stuff, leaving the TVA agents like Mobius
Hunter, B-15,
everyone else to figure out what they're
supposed to be doing all the time.
That's one of the reasons
why they were yelling
at the end of season one, like,
everything's crazy.
What are we supposed to be working on?
He hasn't told us because he's not around.
He's busy
fighting the Kang Multiverse War,
but while there's a larger mystery
about the Kang Multiverse War
and the Kang variants is going on,
the TVA agents, all these people are still
doing their regular day to day missions.
They're still going around
pruning dangerous variants at Nexus.
Events like Mobius
and the TVA are still doing what
they would normally be doing every day.
That's one of the reasons why
they get involved in the plot of Deadpool
three, because Deadpool and Wolverine
wind up running afoul of Mobius, the TVA.
In most minutes
I've been talking about Deadpool three
being like them,
doing a version of Deadpool
kills the Fox Marvel Universe with him
messing up the Fox timeline
because of all the time
traveling he's doing.
That's what we'll put him on.
Mobius in the TVA shit list.
They're going to be shooting Deadpool
three for most of this year,
so we'll get some more footage
of that pretty soon.
This thing of Loki using his magic
to fight people is him just fighting other
TVA agents using one of those same batons,
but he's also using his magic.
That's why you see the green flash.
As you can see, the building behind
them is meant to be similar architecture
from the TVA.
This is just happening
in one of the other new TVA buildings.
Then they're in another new room
revealing the K Quan from
everything everywhere, all at once
is playing a brand new character.
They actually brought him on stage
during the D23 presentation,
like Guess Who We Got?
They said that he's playing
a TVA archivist in the room they're in
just seems like an archives room
where they store really dangerous
or really important items that they don't
just outright destroy
or send to the trash planet in.
Loki makes in everything everywhere
all at once.
Reference.
He says this is about everything
during this scene while they cut this
in the trailer in in the last scene, he's
falling between buildings inside the TVA,
screaming the whole way down like business
as usual for Loki, same as it ever was.
Seems like a disaster
that he's totally failing at,
but somehow manages to pull off a win.
It also seems like Kate Dickie is actually
playing a version of older Sylvie in.
It'll be sort of a twist on
the idea of older Loki like classic Loki.
It'll be a version of Sylvie
who's remorseful about what she did
at the end of season one, causing
the next King Multiverse war to erupt.
And she'll be using her own
TVA agents to go around and try and prune
all these different timelines
and will serve as one of the main
antagonist of the season.
Aside from all the other catching variants
that they're trying to deal with on the
side, most of you will probably remember.
Kate Dickie is Lisa Aaron
from the original Game of Thrones series.
This is Loki talking to Mobius inside
one of their cafeterias.
This designed like a classic automat,
like a classic British automat,
because everything in the TVA
has this very particular design style
that makes it look old timey.
In the scene, he's talking to Mobius
about their current predicament.
It's meant to be a parallel
for their scenes during season one.
In that version of the TVA's lunch room,
where they work through the problem.
How to Find Sylvie.
The next scene is of Loki
in another new room in the TVA,
trying to explain something being held
at the mercy of some other attendant here,
like some of the receptionist.
And this is meant to be
a funny scene of him
getting exasperated with someone
who's not listening to him.
According to the Disney Plus schedules,
they're supposed to be releasing Loki
Season two around July,
which is close to when they released
season one a couple of years ago.
So within expectations, they're also
supposed to release the Star Wars
Ahsoka episodes at the end of the summer
so that all kind of lines up.
I will do a new secret invasion
trailer video as soon as they release one.
And I just started doing The Mandalorian
Season 3 episode videos.
You can click Here
for All My Mandalorian Season
three Episode videos and click here
for that other Loki Season two
First Look video with Loki and Sylvie
to find out what she's doing
when that season picks up.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.